wie ich meine sprache wären ist doch was
ziemlich individuelles solange es ihm
niemandem wehtun wenn man aber sagt ich
will aus prinzip nicht ändern dann
schließlich ja aktiv leute aus das ist
genau das polarisierende wo man auch
glaube ich die leute auf dem weg zu mehr
gleichberechtigung verliert in der hand
zwingt dich anders zu sprechen doch das
ist doch genau das was du möchtest aber
was ist mit denen nicht in ihren
personen sind absolut ignoriert
wo sind die sternchen inkludiert das
schafft realität also man kann sie
ändern und trotzdem entschuldigt
inbegriffen arschloch sein
[Musik]
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer liebe
zuschauer innen oder liebe zuschauenden
den einen bedeutet ländern alles die
anderen sind nur noch genervt geht die
wunderschöne deutsche sprache vor die
hunde mit gender sternchen und binnen i
oder müssen wir in zukunft anders
sprechen um niemanden mehr
auszuschließen alles gender gaga oder
ändert sprache alles darüber müssen wir
sprechen weil dieses thema psychologisch
voller überraschungen und sprengstoff
steckt und zwar bei mir auf der couch
mit zwei hirnen die beim gendern maximal
weit auseinander liegen
[Musik]
in der fdp ist schüler erst 17 er
studiert juda schon neben der schule und
ist auch im verein deutsche sprache hält
die sich gegen das zu ändern einsetzen
sprache was ich immer frei entwickeln
und das heißt es ich finde das richtig
niemand irgendetwas vorgeschrieben
werden sollte er hat sehr viele
argumente gegen die diskussion über
sendern geführt wird und dass da immer
gleich um moral geht und dass wenn man
sagt man will nichts ändern dass man
dann gleich rechts ist und dass man
gleich ein frauenhasser ist ich bin
wirklich dafür dass man die debatte um
das zu ändern in moralisiert
[Musik]
zahlreiche ist kabarettistin und enorm
engagiert bereichs poetry slams sie hat
germanistik und englisch auf lehramt
studiert und engagiert sich unter
anderem für das finde ich bin immer am
start sind irgendwo energie
ich glaube dass theresa das
hauptargument auch dass der
gleichberechtigung ist dass sich
wirklich alle angesprochen fühlen dass
das generische maskulinum vermeintlichen
überbleibsel patriarchaler strukturen
ist und dass es deswegen das
abzuschaffen gilt
wichtiges tool um die gesellschaft mit
zu formen natürlich 1 1 aber ein begriff
[Musik]
das wäre ziemlich genial also wenn wir
patriarchale strukturen nur dadurch
abschaffen können wenn wir jetzt an dass
schülern innen abhängen sofort bitte
aber ich glaube da macht man sich
wirklich viel zu einfach ich glaube dass
wir insgesamt auf das ganze leben
gesehen sehr uneinig sind wann holt die
leute nicht ab in dem man sagt wenn ich
jenna desk automatisch gegen
gleichberechtigung in bayern sagt mal
schauen wir dann sehen wir schon
[Musik]
[Applaus]
theresa torben herzlich willkommen auf
meiner couch danke erstes mal
paartherapie
definitiv ja
und dann direkt mit so einem thema das
ist ein unglaubliches reizthema oder
kochen die gemüter hoch da stellen wir
uns einig wieso ist das so mir geht
meistens oder sich relativ schnell
wütend werde wenn ich sage ich fühle
mich diskriminiert durch etwas und die
gegen peer sondern sagt ja aber das
nervt dieses polarisierender der debatte
kommt es dadurch dass beide seiten so so
sehr auf ihren seiten beharren und die
gender debatte gar nicht als debatte um
das bessere argument begreift sondern
das ist eben sehr schnell in dieses
schwarz weiß denken geht gut böse denken
das führt dann immer zwangs mäßig zu
einer zu einer erhitzung der gemüter
jetzt hat er ganz viel man mit kopfkino
und vorstellungen zu tun und genau da
würde ich euch jetzt gerne in ein
kleines gedankenexperiment mit
reinnehmen tut mir den gefallen habe ich
das wirklich vorzustellen macht mal die
augen zu
ein vater und sein sohn sind auf der
autobahn unterwegs es kommt zu einem
schrecklichen unfall der vater ist
sofort tot der sohn ist so schwer
verletzt dass man ihn in die
unfallklinik bringen muss und da weil er
so schwer verletzt dass ruft man direkt
nach dem boss der unfallchirurgie als
der boss der unfallchirurgie den jungen
sieht sagt er den kann ich nicht
behandeln das ist ja mein sohn
wie kann das gehen der vater war dort
tot das ist der eine klassiker den gibt
immer ich würde wirklich ein sehr sehr
gutes beispiel um zu beweisen dass
frauen eben nicht mitgedacht werden
faktisch was glaubt ihr warum kommen so
wenig hirn
2021 in deutschland auch auf die idee
dass auch eine mutter was der
unfallchirurgie sein kann ein fachlich
meint es generische maskulinum alles
alle geschlechter alle geschlechter
identitäten in der realität ist es aber
so dass wenn man das generische maskulin
benutzt das bei allen leuten eher
männliche bilder hervor ruft alle
schüler der klasse 6a die demonstranten
bei einer demo die studenten im hörsaal
das glaube ich hier im kontext immer
klar dass da sowohl die weiblichen also
die männlichen als auch das gegenteil
weisen tatsächlich nein also wenn er in
der zeitung steht die bürger sind zur
wahl aufgerufen ist jedem im kontext
klar dass damit sowohl männer als auch
frauen gemeint sind sonst würde
gesellschaft gar nicht funktionieren und
theresa fühlst du dich nicht
angesprochen wenn in der zeitung steht
alle bürger sollen zur wahl gehen nicht
wirklich nicht wirklich keinen bürger
sondern die bürgerinnen ja glauben das
ist eine andere begriffsdefinition also
bürger sind wir alle und ich glaube da
kann man auch bewusst missverstehen aber
ich nehme dieses bewusst missverstehen
als anwalts ich will mich nicht
angesprochen fühlen von der männlichen
form oder wenn man wenn man das schon
bewusst sein so sagt dann versucht man
auch ein gewisses problem zu
konstruieren wenn man wirklich sagen ich
will mich bewusst nicht angesprochen
fühlen nein das problem ist ja dass die
leute nicht angesprochen werden wieso
sollte ich mich von was angesprochen
erinnert wie schon gesagt du willst dich
bewusst nicht angesprochen fühlen und
das ist dann ja schon gerade bei
wirklich ding wo es mehr als eindeutig
ist und da können wir sicherlich darauf
einigen alle bürger sind zur wahl
aufgerufen
wir meinen alle schüler einer klasse
dass man da wirklich objektiv sagen kann
alle sind gemeint als frau weiß ja gar
nicht wie es ist die ganze zeit
angesprochen zu werden es ist wirklich
schöner es geht einem wirklich besser
psychisch ist auch wissenschaftlich
bewiesen dass es wirklich mädchen in
klassen soll man besser geht wenn man
das macht sie haben jetzt hier schon ein
gefühl dafür bekommen wo so
grundsätzlich die reise bei euch jeweils
hingehen könnte seid ihr bereit für eine
kleine intervention er merkt traumhaft
dann tut mir gefallen die couch einmal
weg den tisch weg und wir brauchen ein
bisschen platz
[Musik]
die beiden kommen die ziemlich
unterschiedlich vor was die
emotionalität der esa ist voll on fire
toppen er also der ruhige analytische
und da will ich mir jetzt mal angucken
was denn passiert wenn ich hier ein paar
provokante thesen reinbringen ganz
verschiedene standpunkte und das gucken
wir uns freundlich an und zwar entlang
einer linie wiener bleiben die zusammen
und wie weit gehen die auseinander naja
wenn er sagt das was torten da verzapft
das passt mir so gar nicht theresa dann
gehst du ein gutes stück weg wenn du
sagst und da kann ich mich immer wieder
annähernd kommst du auf mich zu
umgekehrt für dich dasselbe ich würde
sagen wir starten bei maximal eng
beieinander niemand sollte aufgrund
seines geschlechts diskriminiert werden
damit das klappt sollten wir schon
anfangen kindern in der grundschule das
gendern beizubringen theresa nicht
sofort torben daher meinung definitiv
nicht da reichen zehn zentimeter nein
also das fest verpflichten beizubringen
ist natürlich absolut nicht der richtige
weg nein also damit damit schafft man
keine gleichberechtigung denn kinder zum
beispiel aufgezogen werden mit ländern
die können ja ändern bevor sie schreiben
und lesen können weil das für die ganz
normales es hilft aber zur
gleichberechtigung warum weil zum
beispiel wenn in schulen geändert wird
sich mädchen deutlich mehr angesprochen
fühlen gerade weil in deutschland die
lage so ist dass man mehr als zwei
drittel ablehnende werte zum gendern hat
und das nicht nur unter männern sondern
genauso unter frauen so dass solange die
gesellschaft ist nicht von alleine macht
der wandel nicht von unten nach oben
stattfindet ich nicht denke das ist
ändern so verpflichtend eingeführt
werden sollte
dies wird zum beispiel ist ein riesen
teil meines studiums gewesen du ziehen
der darauf hinzuweisen dass sich gerne
angesprochen werden würde wenn sie mich
ansprechen das müsstest du jetzt in
deinem studium rauch in der schule nicht
machen weil du bist immer angesprochen
und du bist jetzt gewohnt immer
angesprochen zu sein wichtig ist da
glaube ich nur dass es immer auf
freiwilligkeit auf dem freien austausch
der meinungen diskutiert bei mir ist es
so dass ich das in einer vorlesung noch
nicht mitbekommen habe dass ich daran
leute beschwert habe frauen beschwert
haben ich bin schon ausgeschlossen
worden dass eine vorlesung gleich mit
gewünscht habe von dozenten dass er doch
bitte einmal in der sitzung die
weibliche form benutzt willkommen im
deutschen alltag da gibt es eine
studentin der uni hingeht und sagt ich
fühle mich von euch nicht mit
angesprochen und die dann
rausgeschmissen wird das zeigt wie hier
die gemüter aufgeheizt sind einmal
jemand der sagt ich werfe dich raus kann
ich persönlich überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen aber dann auch theresa
die sagt das ist mir so wichtig ich
riskiere die konfrontation mit jemandem
der in der hierarchie weit über mir
steht respekt dafür und gleichzeitig
merkt man die wut oder oder sagst du
nein ich fahre hier da gehe ich nicht
ein schritt auf sie zu und sagt da
müsste man doch eigentlich jetzt was
ändert das ist ja genau das was wir was
beide glaube ich enorm stört dass man
dann rausgeschmissen werden weil man
eine andere meinung hat in der debatte
und genau denselben fall gibt es ja wenn
sich leute gegen das ständer während es
gibt ja immer mehr fälle an
universitäten wo schon leben von unseren
studenten gezwungen werden in
hausarbeiten in klausuren zu gendern
ansonsten würden sind schlechtere noten
keine meinung dazu ich find's super weil
wenn wenn jemand nicht geändert also
finden es super dass zu bestrafen auf
jeden fall
dieses paternalistische ich möchte die
sprache der anderen greifen das war
wirklich ein punkt der mich sehr gestört
hat ich bin auch schon fast sogar hause
bei durchgefallen weil ich das
generische fellini um verwendet haben
der dozent kein verarbeitet das bedeutet
dann ich sage nicht mehr liebe juristen
zu begrüßen sondern ich sage einfach
liebe juristinnen und unterstelle tor
aber schon meint auch einfach etwas
anderes wird sich nicht angesprochen
fühlen wenn man sagt die juristin ist
grammatikalisch einfach etwas anderes
man kann das ja durch nur durch ein ganz
klares beispiel belegen zum beispiel man
kann sagen die weiblichen schüler aber
man kann eben nicht sagen die männlichen
schüler sind ja aber das ist ja nur
konvention
grammatik beschreibt die sprache wie sie
ist dh die grammatik schreibt nicht vor
wie sprache ist klassik beschreibt
sprach er diplomatisch muss ich nach der
sprache die ich nicht anders um jeder
der gender das ist meistens ein sehr
noble sun liegen kann das gerne tun
wichtig ist eben dass merz nicht tut das
genauso nicht tun sollen dürften sondern
sprache sollte frei sein ohne
irgendwelche begrenzung oder regeln wenn
man aber gesagt ich will aus prinzip
nicht ändern dann schließlich ihr aktiv
leute aus das ist genau das polarisieren
da wo man auch glaube ich die leute auf
dem weg zu mehr gleichberechtigung
verliert wenn man genauso moralisiert
und so polarisiert dass man sagt wer
nicht geändert hat sich bewusst dazu
entschieden menschen auszuschließen aber
das wird teresa will ist das
verpflichtend zwanghaft zu machen und
das sage ich ganz klar und auf sieht das
ding mehr an zwingt dich das zurecht
doch das ist doch genau das was du
möchtest ob ich jetzt anders sprechen
muss oder anders schreiben muss da ist
der übergang nur noch fließend wenn ich
so nicht bewerten und studenten dazu
zwingen bestimmte andere von der
eigentlichen norm abweichenden
grammatikalischen regeln zu verwenden
obwohl die mehrheit sagt sie möchte das
nicht und das ist ein unglaublicher
eingriff in die sprache also ich sollte
doch als person das bedürfnis haben dass
ich es möglich zu sprechen dass alle ok
damit sind und sich niemand angegriffen
fühlt von mir ich bin so lange dagegen
dass in staatlichen institutionen im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk gesendet
wird bis sich ein wirklicher wandel
innerhalb der gesellschaft von zu wie
soll sich dann aber die gesellschaft
wandeln wenn es niemand vor lebt von
unten nach oben es steht dir als
künstlerin frei zu gendern aber den
sprachwandel von oben nach unten zu
vollziehen das ist der falsche weg damit
nimmst du die leute auch nicht meter
brett stehen oder gehen wir grade wieder
auseinander
die rechtschreibreform ist ein bisschen
ein anderer fall weil ich denke hier hat
ja schon sehr politische gründe obmann
tür mit th oder ohne haar schreibt ist
was völlig anderes als dieses ich will
mir nicht vorschreiben lassen wie ich zu
sprechen habe doch du lässt dir 24/7
vorschreiben von grammatik und von der
rechtschreibung video zu sprechen hast
wohl anders ist darf sich gerne 1000
euro wenn du jetzt türme th schreiben
willst dann diskriminiert du niemanden
da geht es an den ganz intimen punkt
wenn es darum geht wie viel sprache
dürfen wir vorschreiben wie hart dürfen
werden die sprache des einzelnen
eingreifen da reagiert sehr sensibel
wenn wir uns die zahlen an gucken haben
wir relativ drastische werte in
deutschland gegen das gendern 71 prozent
sind gegen ein welche trennungs zeichen
wie sternchen oder stimmen pausen bei
professor pause immer und selbst bei
keiner partei gibt es eine mehrheit für
das zu ändern wenn so viele dagegen sind
warum dann doch sagen wir es fühlt sich
nur fünf prozent der bevölkerung
diskriminiert von generischen maskulinum
wieso kann ich nicht dieses dieser diese
kleine pause mit diesen kleinen innen
mit sprechen damit die leute sich das
problem die ganz ganz woanders also wenn
man sagt dass sich da leute
diskriminiert fühlen wir haben bei nicht
belehren eine höhere diskussions rate
wir haben eine furchtbare
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz diese
menschen gegenüber hier muss man doch an
setzten sich am meisten nervt ist glaube
ich dass gender an das einzige mittel
ist wahre gleichberechtigung in unserem
land einzufordern zu erreichen du setzt
ja voraus dass wenn du die menschen
zwingt auf einmal diese menschen die
gesellschaftliche akzeptanz nicht
binären oder frauen gegenüber steigern
das ist doch quatsch also man kann sie
ändern und trotzdem entschuldigt den
begriffen arschloch sein sprache schafft
realität und man muss die leute schon
ein bisschen schubsen vielleicht auch
mal aus der eigenen babbel daraus zu
gucken was mir auffällt wir haben zwei
klare position ihr seid nicht mehr am
maximum es gab schöne dynamik wurde
zwischendurch auch wenn dazu dann auch
wieder auseinander gegangen seid lasst
uns zusammen auf die couch kommen und
gucken wo wir jetzt inzwischen stand
dieser übung nämlich auf jeden fall mit
dass theresa und ich punkte haben wo wir
übereinander stimmen das ziel mehr
gleichberechtigung und uns eben in den
mitteln und wegen teilweise sehr
fundamental gegenüberliegen theresa wenn
du jetzt toben zuhörst und wie auf der
linie schon so viel dynamik arten wo
bist du am meisten getriggert wenn du
sagst es nicht ändern keine
diskriminierung ist und du umgekehrt wo
sagst du da provoziert er sah mich
vielleicht dieses vorschreiben
demoralisieren also eigentlich genau das
umgekehrte dass theresa sagt dass jeder
der im generischen maskulinum spricht
bewusst diskriminiert
die frage ist nicht zu ändern oder nicht
die frage ist wieder ändern wenn leute
zu dir kommen und sagen ich fühle mich
diskriminiert von generischen maskulinum
und du hältst trotzdem weiter deine
reden und eine interviews im generischen
maskulinum dann tust du das in dem
wissen dass leute sich davon
diskriminiert fühlen und so
funktionierts gesellschaft auch nicht
wenn ich jeden fragen müsste wie fühlst
du dich jetzt mit meiner ansprache
so funktioniert das nicht wenn man vor
100 leuten spricht wenn man
gesellschaftlich spricht sprache ist ein
kommunikationsmittel für den
alltäglichen gebrauch darum ist es nicht
alles viel zu komplizierten es ist nicht
alles unnötig und es ist nicht alles
dritte ich kann doch auch genauso sagen
dass ich gar keinen diskriminieren
möchte wieso kommt da nicht die andere
seite auf einen zu und sagt okay dann
glaube ich dir dass dieses dieses
nachbohren du änderst du denn das nicht
ich finde nicht dass man das begründen
muss sondern wie ich meine sprache
wählen ist doch was ziemlich
individuelles solange sie niemandem
wehtut es ist halt nicht wie es
funktioniert ich muss mir halt von den
betroffenen sagen lassen was es
diskriminierend dann muss ich mich
anpassen und nichts sagen aber ich finde
es ist nicht diskriminierend also
wo stehen wir und vor allem was fühlen
wir das natürlich unfassbar schwer zu
greifen gerade wenn man sagt ich habe so
eine erfahrung vielleicht nie gemacht
das hat ganz viel auch mit
gesellschaftlichen position sanktionen
ich hab was für euch dabei aus der
psychologie dass sie jetzt glaube ich
perfekt passen würde wo wir genau das
mal sichtbar machen können argumente
zahlen daten fakten studien davon haben
die beiden ziemlich viel im gepäck aber
ich möchte als psychologe natürlich auch
wissen wie es die stimmung zwischen
ihnen was steht im zweifel auch zwischen
den beinen das machen wir jetzt mal ganz
bildlich in dem wir skulpturen bauen und
ich bin sehr gespannt wie die beiden
diese völlig unterschiedlich bisher hier
durchgehend damit umgehen theresa du
fängst an torben ist ein granitblock
dürftig ist beispielweise meinen arm
nehmen und sagen wieso eine bildhauerin
den abend brauche ich so sobald sie
fertig mit einem formel ist sagte
matschies und ich mach ein foto von euch
du bist nämlich teil der skulptur mit
ihm fertig bist stellst du dich noch
passend dazu und dann halten wir fest
wie du die situation einordnen kannst du
dir die ohren zuhalten ja ich kann dir
jetzt tatsächlich aus dem schultheater
mit diesen statuen das aber hat er
unterschied dass wir uns alle gekannt
haben und machten wie stehst du jetzt
dazu passt so achtung
ich möchte jetzt einmal die rollen
tauschen du wirst zum bildhauer und du
bist ja gern in block deine du hast dich
ja ratssitzung herum und zeigefingern so
einen lehrer jeder den
lehrerinnen dank individuell immer
schauen lehrerin guckst auch ziemlich
böse und verärgert das ist gut und dann
hast du so ein weg von mir ja genauso
was und den er so auf mich herab schauen
möchte noch den schüler zudem ist ein
bisschen höher stellen ja das wäre
genial wenn wenn sie sich da so drauf
stellt würde ja nicht fallen
du sollst schießt trocken wenn ihr
bereits und
wir bauen zurück und besprechen auf der
couch
[Musik]
ich gebe mal das erste foto vielleicht
mag es wir schreiben was du siehst gibt
dem überschrift was war der titel für
dieses kunstwerk
hören wir doch zu was ich wollte war
bitten dass vilja wollte bitten aber hör
mir doch zu ist glaube ich tatsächlich
der gute titel ich bitte dich um etwas
und du hörst wenig zu und schaut weg und
sagst aus prinzip nein ich habe versucht
auf ihre gefühle einzugehen und ihr das
zu erklären dass sie dennoch den
eindruck hatte ich würde nicht zu hören
und sogar mit dem rücken zu ihr stehen
das finde ich dann eher traurig und das
muss wirklich deutlich werden dass ich
niemandem verbieten möchte sondern das
ist genauso gut wie nichts zu ändern ich
bin ja in dem fall die diskriminierte
ich muss darum bitten nicht
diskriminiert zu werden und das sieht er
aber nicht ich gebe euch mal die zweite
reihe
beschreiben
ich bin völlig übertrieben am gc cool
ihren und am belehren und am becken
gleichzeitig und du machst eigentlich
gar nichts ich höre mir das an okay er
hat mich letztlich für sich gestellt sah
vielleicht an diese ab und das teile ich
mit ganz vielen in der debatte dass sich
die die andere seite das gegenüber
zumindest fühlt es sich so an immer sehr
moralisierend somit erhobenen
zeigefinger ich belehre die ich jetzt
mal richtig spricht zeige dir wie du
dich anderen richtig zu verhalten aus
das ist ja das ding mit diskriminierung
ich fühle mich diskriminiert wenn ich
nicht angesprochen werde und wenn leute
sich dann weigern mich anzusprechen
obwohl ich ihnen sage ich würde gerne
angesprochen werden fühle ich mich noch
mehr diskriminiert und dann wird aber
von mir als betroffene erwartet dass ich
eine komplett sachliche ohne emotionale
diskussion führe in einer diskussion in
der es darum geht dass mir weh getan
wird was hier gerade passiert erlebe ich
als psychologe ganz oft dann heißt es
achten gefühle das in welche dusel ein
oder emotionen diego im weg stehen weil
wir wollen doch rational seien in dieser
welt und das ein riesiger trugschluss
unsere gefühle sind unsere realität was
ich fühle ist meine wahrnehmung und da
kann niemand dran dh wenn theresa sagt
das ist mein gefühl da kann nichts mehr
sagen das finde ich falsch oder ich
würde mich ganz anders fühlt aber es
bleibt ihr gefühl wenn du jetzt den
punkt vom turm aber aufgreift und dieses
bild noch mal für dich ja in den titel
verschießt was glaubst du kommt dann bei
tormann von deiner haltung und wie
nennst du das kunstwerk ist
wahrscheinlich die belehrung von oben
ich komme ja aber von unten ja bestehen
der gesellschaft unter titel war ja die
frage wie ihr es war nicht das ding ist
ja auch niemand will eine private
sprache eingreifen was du mit deiner
freundin und einem vater und seinem
bruder im auto
ist komplett eure sachen natur losgesagt
aber sobald haltung was offizielles geht
sobald es eine hausarbeit ist sobald es
nachrichten sind können wir uns dann
nicht darauf einigen dass es schon schön
wäre wenn man alle anspricht und das
ding mit grammatik ist ja auch das ist
grammatik ist kein neutrales ding das
einfach passiert es männer haben
grammatik gebaut und da hat sich die
frage nach ländern sehr lange nicht
gestellt wenn wir uns darauf einigen
können dass sich sprache verändern kann
möchte ich jetzt mal mit euch ganz
praktisch gucken wie könnte das aussehen
das soll ich was für euch mitgebracht
und ich würde euch bitte noch einmal
mehr aufzustellen
also theoretisch ist hier schon mal klar
nichts ist klar denn wir müssen wir aber
praktisch in unserer gesellschaft mit
sprache weiter nehmen und das möchte ich
jetzt sehen wie gehen die beiden mit
herausforderungen der deutschen sprache
um wenn es ans ländern geht und dann
würde ich euch jetzt bitten zusammen als
team natürlich mit diskussion aber vor
allem lösungsorientiert mir einen
vorschlag zu machen für das dürft ihr
bitte einmal da hinten folgendes wort
aber dann lasst uns leichter erklären wo
jetzt da das problem ist ob jetzt also
ernsthaft eine lehrerin denkt sie könne
diesen raum nicht betreten
oder sie sei beim begriff lehrerzimmer
nicht mit gemeint es ist ein zimmer
voller lehrkräfte wieso stehen nur die
männlichen lehrer dar wieso soll das
nicht ein bedürfnis sein alle leute
aufzuschreiben ok du bist ein weißer
hetero mann du kannst es wirklich nicht
wissen und deshalb finde ich sollte
vielleicht auch gedanklich irgendwann so
weit sein zu sagen okay ich weiß nicht
wie es sich anfühlt uns glaubt ihr jetzt
ist einfach wenn man jetzt sagt
lehrkraft zimmer oder so ohne dass ein
großer bürokratischer aufwand entsteht
und man jetzt überall die türschilder ab
nagelt und extra neu dran macht da würde
ich mich auch gar nicht verwehrt sprache
ist ja was historisch ganz lange
gewachsen ist und begriffe 11
austauschen zu wollen ich glaube ich
weder zielführend noch sehr einfach
jetzt lege ich noch eine schippe drauf
ihr beiden bürgermeisterkandidaten
muss ich werde mit dem wort sehr sehr
zufrieden wenn es in einem gesetz steht
dann muss es auf jeden fall kandidatin
wenn man das jetzt wirklich ganz
konsequent machen würde was zur leser
als die letzte zeit erzielt hatte wies
ist ja eigentlich bürger/innen meister
in kandidatin wenn man das jetzt gleich
sieht dann kann man sich natürlich schon
die frage stellen ob das jetzt noch
sinnvoll ist ob dadurch diskriminiert
abgeschafft ist
wenn wir dann wirklich zweimal innen und
drei sterne in einem kleinen wort sind
wie absurd das dann auf einmal werden
kann das werde ich so schnell nicht
vergessen das ist auch nicht meine
lösung ich finde darf dann einfach ein
neues wort vorschlag
und dann hat er noch ganz gemein sagt
loos hat germanistik studieren wer wenn
nicht du
denkst du nicht dass wenn gesetze
wirklich so geschrieben werden du dann
auch wirklich beginnt menschen
auszugrenzen wir werden das gerät also
da braucht man sich ja vielleicht schon
ein gewisses leseverständnis solche
begriffe zu entschlüsseln das ist ja
dann auch immer dass das argument von
den extremen gender gegner innen da
müsse man die komplette deutsche sprache
um familien weil dann heißt ja
freundinnen schafft und nachbarinnen
schafft und so bürgermeister kandidatin
ist ja die eine person die da kandidiert
ja und die bürger sind ganz viele und
das ist ein idealisiertes wort aber
begrenzt das ab also man nachschauen
dass das video mattiert ist es passiert
sowieso nicht alles auf einmal das ist
ja ein wandel mein ding ist nur man muss
halt irgendwo anfangen deswegen wäre ich
komplett fein mit
bürgermeisterkandidatin ein
moment von drei männer sternchen wenn
jetzt zwei gestrichen das hast du immer
noch nein nein sie suchen nach dem
kompromiss daran darf ich erinnern weil
ich drauf sonst ein gegenvorschlag von
demo teresa mit geht also ich glaube
gesellschaftlich akzeptierter wäre wenn
man einfach schreibe bürgermeister
kandidatin oder kandidat also oder zwei
angriffe auf macht aber was ist mit
denen ich trainieren personen sind
absolut inkludiert wo sind hier dem
sternchen inkludiert das sternchen das
ist die gender gap das sind die nicht in
ihren personen das ist wie gender gap
funktioniere aber dann sind sie also
dann muss es ja wirklich konsequent
machen also du kannst ja nicht mal
meistens im osten ist es mich in ordnung
fand mein kompromissvorschlag
bürgermeister kandidatin oder kandidat
fand ich gut so denn identität ist so
viel mehr als die hat man nur mit mit
der gender gap theresa es ist wirklich
sehr gut da das also mittlerweile
geschlechter können so vielfältig sei
wieso wir uns dann nicht darauf einigen
dass eben das generische maskulinum
wirklich für alle gilt dann könnte man
sich solche debatten ja viel ersparen
ich wäre mit unterstrich mit sternchen
mit doppelpunkt
mit schrägstrich der schrägstrich ist ja
ist ja vielleicht mal was anderes
dann kaufe ich den rauch älter
vielleicht so ein schrägstrich
bindestrich
wenn beide mit dem kompromiss
unzufrieden sind ist es glaube ich ganz
guter kompromiss der luft weit mit einer
chefin hast frage erst einen kollegen
nach seiner meinung vorgesetzte ist das
eine sehr genau so many würde fast chef
ikaria sein wenn ich das jetzt sehen
wann man will nur irgendein der regel
für ein unternehmen formulieren man
stellt sich die muss sich dann solche
fragen stellen in der formulierung das
zeigt doch also dass es in der sache
wirklich relativ wenig relevanz hat nein
das zeigt dass die sprache das nicht man
lernt so weit ist wie sie sein sollte
das ist ja ein komisches weltbild das
dass es irgendein bild der sprache geben
sollte wie sie sein sollte sondern wir
haben doch gerade festgestellt wie
entwickelt sich frei und die entwickelt
sich durch die verwender ich würde sagen
als vorschlag wenn du streit mit seiner
chefetage horst frage erst beim
mitarbeiten denn um meinung jemanden aus
der mitarbeiterschaft oder ist das auch
jemanden aus der mitarbeiterschaft
geht auch ich freue mich total dass wir
selbst bei sowas wo man vielleicht erst
mal vorstellen sagt keine chance am ende
doch eine art lösung zumindest gefunden
deswegen vielen vielen dank dass ihr so
mitgemacht habe ich würde sagen wir
gehen zurück auf die couch
über die genaue umsetzung kann man sich
muss man sich wahrscheinlich noch
ziemlich viel streiten es gibt aber eine
erste untersuchung aus deutschland die
zeigt wenn man leute einen geschlechts
gerechten text lesen lässt dass sie
danach eher geschlechts gerechte sprache
benutzen das heißt allein das lesen
scheint schon etwas mit den köpfen zu
machen spannend dabei ist aber dass das
nur für frauen gilt männer muss man noch
mal explizit darauf hinweisen dass da
geschlechts gerechte sprache drin
vorkommt wenn wir nochmal die tafel
denken und die gefühle die dabei
vielleicht auch auf kamen wo hast du für
dich gemerkt teresa und das ist
vielleicht auch einfach nervig das ist
schwierig das kostet die ganze zeit
kraft im kopf männer haben die deutsche
sprache geformt und das merkt man in
allen in allen belangen der sprache das
ist natürlich jetzt schwierig wenn man
die sprache bisschen feminisierung will
wo fängt man an und wo hört auf kann man
nicht vielleicht mal anfangen dass man
nur wenn es auch nur die direkt der
anrede ist dass man da geändert damit
sich möglichst alle angesprochen fühlen
im plural gefragt genau nach deinem
gefühl wenn es darum geht ist dass wut
haben deine gefühle wenn du da stehst
man sieht ja wenn man theresa sie fühlt
sich unwohl diskriminiert dann muss man
darauf natürlich eingeben ich glaube ich
habe das bessere argument aber würde
nicht sagen es ist mir egal was sie sagt
da ist mir tatsächlich auch von dass der
der knackpunkt ist dass er nicht denkt
diskriminiert wenn er nicht absichtlich
diskriminiert
also ich spüre und versuche da zu viel
wie so viele leute sie so darüber
aufregen ich will dir nur aufzeigen wenn
du so versucht sprache so zu ändern
zwanghaft zu ändern nach festen
amerikanischen normen zu ändern nie zu
einem ergebnis wo sich alle wirklich mit
glücklich fühlen wenn die leute sagen
ich fühle mich diskriminiert wenn du nur
von studenten sprichst und du änderst
deine form zu sprechen nicht dann weißt
du du diskriminiert leute und du tust
ist trotzdem doch nein weil ich sie
objektiv in meinen augen nicht
diskriminieren aber ob du siehst kannst
du fröhliche treiben ihre es ist die
entscheidung des betroffenen ob sie
diskriminiert werden oder nicht das
finde ich so schwierig deswegen zu sagen
wir krempeln alles um in der sprache wir
schreiben allen alles vor weil du mir zu
schreibt ich würde bewusst
diskriminieren ich verstehe wirklich das
problem nicht wenn es zwei versionen
gibt und die 1 männlich geschändet und
die andere gilt für alle ist es dann
wirklich so viel arbeit sich von der
einen auf die ampel form umzugewöhnen
wir haben nur zwei möglichkeiten aktuell
und deshalb bin ich auch dafür dass wo
immer das geht studierende lehrende dass
man da eine form für alle findet aber
diese eine form für alle ist nicht
männliche form gelesen am häusern auf
turms stürmt könnten wir hier richtung
kompromiss kommen
also sofern sich das durchsetzt und
immer mehr leute sagen sie würden das
machen dann würde ich mich nicht wehren
also ich glaube da ist sprache auch
mächtig genug das so weit so viele
verwender das wirklich nutzen das ist
ziemlich schwierig ist dann dagegen
anzukommen weil man sich einfach sonst
verständigen kann wenn jeder denkt ihr
können jetzt seine eigene
grammatikalischen sachen durchsetzen
also du würdest warten bis es die
mehrheit ist und dann würdest du
mitmachen ich glaube nicht dass es die
mehrheit wird aber dieses zurückgezogene
verharren würde ich nicht machen nein
das problem die herausforderung wenn wir
hier heute nicht lösen deswegen möchte
ich auf der zielgeraden auch etwas mit
euch machen ich würde euch bitten
vielleicht noch einmal aufzustehen
wie gehe ich aus einem streit raus und
das hat jeder und jede von uns
sicherlich im privaten schon mal erlebt
da kann man die türen knallen und dann
trennen sich die wege und hoffentlich
läuft man sich ein paar tage später
wieder über den weg man kann aber auch
versuchen okay bei all dem negativen was
wir hier auf gewählt haben bei alldem
gegeneinander wo sind vielleicht doch
noch punkte die uns verbinden und vor
allem was finde ich vielleicht doch auch
gut an dir obwohl ich ganz viel ablehne
und genau das möchte ich jetzt machen
reicht euch doch mal bitte die hände und
guckt euch ja wenn ihr damit einfach
beide ende ja einfach so und jetzt tut
mir den gefallen abwechselnd sagt dem
anderen der anderen etwas
wertschätzendes aus eurer sicht zu dem
thema kriegen wir drei punkte hin ich
bin grundsätzlich keine gros der
körperkontakt freundinnen mit leuten die
ich mich kennt und gar nicht es war
schon bissl wird dazu stehen mit den
händen zusammen ich bin zwar nicht gut
wie das du dich damit auseinandersetzt
und nicht alles aus dem fenster schmeißt
er wirklich wertschätzt sehr dass du
siehst dass das dieses auf doktorierende
jenner sprache bei einigen wirklich
negative assoziationen hervorruft und
dass das in der debatte auf jeden fall
ein punkt ist ich bin sehr gut von dir
dass du nicht ändern hast sondern dem
neutral gegenüberstehen dann wiederum
hättest wenn es jemand macht ich finde
sehr gut ist so dicht der debatte stellt
und ich glaube dass dieses
moralisierende weniger bei dir zu finden
ist im sinne von orten schubladen ein
wert ändert ist gut wenn ich jenna
diskriminiert bewusst sondern dass das
differenzieren da finde ich gut ich wenn
auch gut dass so auseinander
differenzieren kannst dass die leute die
gerne ländern nicht unbedingt alle leute
hassen die nicht ändern ich finde oder
fender ist sehr schön wenn du als
künstlerin lydia bist haben sprachwandel
teil hasst und so glaube ich hingegen
publikum erreicht wodurch zusprachen
formen kann und das aufgabe des der
gesellschaft ist und nicht des staates
sie hat gesagt so wie das versuchen das
hat mich gefreut weil
ich keine ewig zuhören und auch zu
kommen ist ein schönes bild was hier
abgeht noch einen platz
unglaublich da waren jetzt so viele
sachen drin da war so viel wertschätzung
wo ich dachte nach alldem streiten kommt
ihr gar nicht mehr zusammen aber jetzt
hab ich fast das gefühl paartherapie
braucht er nicht mehr erfolgreich oder
den rest klärt ihr zuhause jetzt danke
ich euch beiden wirklich genau dafür für
diese diskussion für das streiten für
unsere kleine paartherapie der meinung
bei mir auf der couch vielen dank dass
ihr da wart und für alle kilometer die
sprachlich und sonst im leben noch für
euch links alles gut ich fand's super
ich glaube ich sagen ich habe ziemlich
gut gezeigt das ist ein hitziges thema
ist sondern dass man sehr wohl sehr
unterschiedlicher meinung sein kann
trotzdem persönliche wertschätzung und
finden kann wenn hier die mittellinie
ist dann stehe so zur meter noch dann
ebenso er hat fasten ja es passt da
glaube werde in der debatte noch mehr
diskutieren können wenn es in seinem
engen freundeskreis oder in seiner engen
familie passiert wenn da die
diskussionen kommen das kann vielleicht
etwas ändern vielleicht verliebt dass
ich irgendwann immer denn das aktivisten
ich glaube dass wir beim gender noch
lange nicht am ende der reise angekommen
sind was wir doch heute an tom und
theresa gesehen haben war dass wenn man
nicht übereinander sondern miteinander
redet und vielleicht versucht an
bestimmten punkt mal aufeinander
zuzugehen dass es dann plötzlich
lösungen gibt wo vorher niemand damit
gerechnet hätte das irgendeinen
kompromiss überhaupt möglich ist
das war es schon wieder mit der folge
auf der couch aber ich würde sagen jetzt
machen wir die arena mal so richtig auf
und zwar unten in den kommentaren bitte
sag mir wie haltet ihr es mit dem
ländern mit der geschlechtergerechten
sprache was ist eure meinung dazu alles
erlaubt und wird sagen wir lassen die
fetzen fliegen ansonsten noch so einen
daumen hoch da lassen das würde mich
sehr freuen wenn euch die diskussion
gefallen hat und wenn ihr den kanal
abonniert wisst ihr als erstes wenn es
eine neue folge gibt bis dahin